♪♪
-Hey, everybody. Welcome back.
It's that time of week again.
Old Corrections.
We're gonna just jump right
into it, if you don't mind.
I think it was yesterday we were
talking about Rudy Giuliani
using an Abraham Lincoln filter,
and we said he was talking
like a character
from "Grand Theft Auto:
Civil War."
A couple of you pointed out
it wouldn't be called that
'cause there were no autos
during the Civil War.
Would have to be
"Grand Theft Wagon"
"Grand Theft Horse."
It's just laziness
on Sal's part.
[ Laughter ]
Last week in the monologue,
we had a joke about
the Philadelphia Flyers mascot,
Gritty, being an anti-vaxxer,
and a bunch of people
reached out to say,
hey, Gritty has actually been
a part of a pro-vaccine
campaign online.
So we would like
to both apologize to Gritty
And point out to anyone
who is anti-vax
that you are crazier
than [bleep] Gritty.
[ Laughter ]
This is very embarrassing.
I can't remember.
It might have been
Monday's "Closer Look."
Miming a phone call...
then went to get a pen...
put the phone over here...
and then leaned my head
that way.
[ Laughter ]
Which is a shame 'cause I --
I don't want to toot
my own horn, but I feel like...
when it comes to doing
one-sided phone-call comedy,
I am the new Bob Newhart.
The Bob Newhart, if you will.
[ Laughter ]
Graphics.
Get to graphics, as I tend to.
We talked about Donald Trump
being gifted from Saudi Arabia
a cheetah fur robe,
but in the graphic, he was
wearing a leopard-print robe.
Now, I was pretty upset
about this, but then
our head riser -- our head
writer, excuse me -- Alex Baze,
came up to me and said,
"If you ask me...
no matter what fur Donald Trump
wears, it's cheat-ah."
And I was like, "Oof. Baze."
Not your best, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
We did a very well-received
10,000 Maniacs joke.
[ Laughter ]
But in the key,
it was a photo of the band
in its current incarnation
with lead singer Mary Ramsey
and not Natalie Merchant.
And...
Pretty upset about it,
went down graphics,
and said,
"Obviously, I'm very upset
that you chose
to put in Mary Ramsey
instead of Natalie Merchant.
Do you have anything
to say about that?"
And they said, "You're old."
[ Laughter ]
This is the weird one
from Graphics this week
that a lot of --
And just I think in general,
if a band's lineup
changes graphics,
you should check with me.
You know what I mean?
If I talk about Genesis,
don't just assume
I want Phil Collins
as the lead singer.
I might want Peter Gabriel.
I want the originals
more often than not.
Especially with Genesis,
because that's
what "Genesis" means.
The origin!
All right, so, we did --
We asked --
Again, this is what
we ask Graphics.
We're like,
"Hey, can we get a...
angry grandpa at a Lowe's?"
So a lot of people are like,
"Hey, why is it
aisle 61, aisle 62...
and then aisle 17?"
And I got to be honest.
I'm like 50/50
this is some QAnon [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Like, it would surprise me
not at all
if the Graphics Department
were full Q believers
who are sending signals
and messages out...
to their ilk.
I went down and I said,
"What do you think happened
on January 6th?"
And they said, "A gathering."
[ Laughter ]
Monologue joke.
We told a monologue joke
about how some lions
at a zoo
tested positive for COVID
and that the lions
are doing fine
and they're certainly
doing better
than whoever it was
that had to give them a swab.
And then we showed a tombstone
that said "R.I.P."
And someone wrote,
"Tombstones
don't just say 'R.I.P.'
They have a person's name
and, you know, the dates
of their birth and death."
And then this is what
I've come to really enjoy,
which is sort of
cross-jackal talk.
Someone else jumped in and said,
"Maybe in this case,
'R.I.P.' was cause of death."
[ Laughter ]
"I have bad news, ma'am.
Your husband wandered
into the lion cage,
and there was a rip."
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations are in order.
I hope you guys don't mind
that I'm gonna take a little
time out from Corrections.
I would like to congratulate
my dear friend Colin Jost,
who on Saturday passed me
as the longest-serving
"Weekend Update" anchor.
155 episodes
hosted by Colin Jost.
And I'm so proud of him.
I think he and Che
do a great job.
A few people
have come up to me and said,
"Did it make you sad
to have your record broken?"
And, um, I moved on.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
I'm good.
On my own terms!
And I've got a job!
I mean, I've hosted
like 1,200 of these,
while Jost has done his 155.
I got an everyday job.
Old fat-cat Jost
doing once a week?
Rolling out on Saturday,
You're all throwing crowns
at his feet?
No, thank you!
Also, he has had it easy.
All his "Updates," most of them
during the Trump era...
when the jokes wrote themselves.
And they did -- for us, too.
A lot of people said, "Did
the jokes write themselves?"
And they did.
We would leave, and we'd
just come back to the office,
and the jokes would be there.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know the story?
Shoemaker?
The shoemaker and the elves?
It was like that.
Except we didn't have, like,
a kindly old shoemaker.
We had our Shoemaker.
So every night he'd be like,
"You elves better
write these jokes,
or I'm throwing you
out the window!"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna stick one of those
pointy-toed boots
up your you-know-what!"
[ Laughter ]
And I'd say, "Shoemaker,
don't yell at the elves."
And he goes, "Oh, yeah?
Now we can't yell at the elves?!
This is cancel culture
run amok!"
[ Laughter ]
I go,
"What does that even mean?"
He goes,
"I don't know what it means.
I just know if you say it,
cha-ching."
I was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like...
I feel like this is bills.
Like dollar bills. Cha-ching.
[ Laughter ]
Scollins wrote this joke.
Amid global supply chain delays,
toy makers are reportedly
planning to release
more small, squishy toys
this holiday season.
"You mean rabbits?"
asked Lennie.
And then we showed Lennie
from "Of Mice and Men."
I then -- I referred to it
as "Mice and Men,"
and a bunch of people jumped out
and said it's "Of Mice and Men."
So apologies to...
John Steinbeck.
And then a teacher...
reached out to say,
"You know, I'm actually teaching
this right now to my sophomores,
and the joke doesn't work
because..."
And I should note --
there's nothing novel
about finding
why a Scollins joke
doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
But she said
Lennie dreamed of rabbits,
but in the book,
Lennie only killed a puppy
and Curley's wife.
To which I wanted to say...
"She has a name!"
But then I looked it up.
She doesn't.
Whole book.
Just "Curley's wife."
How about that?
And then Steinbeck reached out.
[ Laughter ]
he didn't reach out,
but I read a quote.
I found an old Steinbeck quote.
And he actually said
there was a reason Curley's wife
was only ever referred to
as Curley's wife,
which is she was not a person.
She was a symbol.
She was there to serve
as a foil for Lennie,
a danger to Lennie.
But I think
that's just an excuse.
I think Steinbeck
was just, like, bad
at coming up with names.
You know what I mean?
The original "Mice and Men"
was just called
"Smarty Pants and Big Guy."
[ Laughter ]
Or he had a perfect name...
and he couldn't remember it.
You know, sometimes you write...
and you have something --
you know you have something.
You think about it before you're
falling to bed or whatever,
and you wake up,
you can't remember it.
And then you can't come up
with anything else
'cause you know
you have the perfect one.
And I'm sure his editor
came over and was like,
"You don't remember the name,
do you?
That's why it's 'Curley's wife.'
You don't remember the name."
And he said,
"Of course I remember it."
And the editor said,
"What is it?"
And Steinbeck said...
"Mulva?"
[ Laughter ]
"Laurie-ohla?"
And then the editor left.
And then Steinbeck was like...
And he ran to the window, and
he yelled down to the editor,
and he said, "Dolores!"
[ "Seinfeld" riff plays ]
[ Laughter ]
We told a Baby Hitler joke
this week.
Because we like to laugh.
[ Chuckles ]
Do we have
the Baby Hitler photo?
There we go. Um...
I mean, it took so long
to find a kid with the mustache.
You can put it down.
[ Chuckles ]
So, this was interesting.
Someone, um...
[ Chuckles ]
Someone wrote a Correction,
and then I noticed
that the first line of the --
It said "Correction,"
but then there was a line
through the "Correction,"
which they had gone back --
They had edited their own
comment, because they said,
hey, Hitler doesn't have
blue eyes. He had brown eyes.
Brown hair, brown eyes.
Obviously used a stock photo
of a baby with blue eyes,
but that couldn't
have been Baby Hitler.
And then someone else --
Again, cross-jackal discourse --
said, "Correction of Correction.
He actually had blue eyes
and brown hair,
and since most pictures of him
are black-and-white,
people tend to assume
that he had brown eyes
to go along with his hair
and his uniform.
There are many statements
by eyewitnesses confirming
that he had blue eyes,
including by Goebbels."
[gerbuhlz]
And if you can't trust
Goebbels...
I feel like I'm saying
his name wrong, but...
This is great. I think
I've talked about this before.
When I'm not sure
I'm pronouncing something right,
I waste my time
and I go on YouTube
to one of those
"how to pronounce things."
And you type in
"how to pronounce Goebbels."
And then it's that thing
where a swirl comes in
and then says the name.
And the only reason
I'm bringing it up...
is, again, you enter in
"how to pronounce
Joseph Goebbels,"
then you hit "play,"
and there was a pre-roll ad
for, like, a clothing company.
[ Laughs ]
And so it was, like,
super-young, beautiful people
being like...
♪ Da-na, deh-deh-deh-deh-deh ♪
And then it was like,
"Joseph Goebbels!"
[ Laughter ]
I've talked about
how some people have said, um...
"I don't believe
you have an audience.
I think it's a laugh track."
And we addressed this last week,
that it's an audience.
In the beginning of the show,
there's a reverse shot.
That's the only time
we show them.
But that should prove
there's an audience.
There is a --
There was a comment
that I have to read
because I will admit --
Very, very mean,
but I enjoyed it a great deal.
They think it's a laugh track
because they can't believe
you get actual humans to laugh.
[ Laughter ]
My second-favorite comment
of the week.
[ Chuckles ]
Scollins. I know he keeps
coming up. I apologize.
Scollins wrote a joke --
he's from Massachusetts --
ragging on his home state
a little bit.
I don't know if this is why
this person wrote this,
but the hyper-specificity of it
is so New England
that I enjoyed a great deal.
I'm gonna read it
with a Boston accent.
I don't know if this person
actually has one or not,
so this is poetic license.
[Boston accent]
"Ask Scollins why his town
doesn't have a decent hotel!"
[ Laughter ]
Um, my former nemesis --
I wore this last time out
when we did this --
Patty Lyons...
seamstress extraordinaire...
made this Jackal Power hat,
and then at the end, I said --
I revealed
that it was double-sided,
and I showed the other side
of it, and then a lot of people
said all hats are double-sided.
If it has -- If it has one side,
it's a picture of a hat.
I give Graphics a hard time.
I really do.
But...
Tara in Graphics.
Every week,
pretty much every week,
I request --
not with a lot of warning --
a different mug.
And for Halloween,
I had a couple of ideas.
And I'm not gonna tell you.
I think you guys can
figure out over there.
So, there's --
there's one, right?
Think we all know.
But this one, I'm really --
This one's, like, a deeper cut.
This one's, like, for obvious,
like, basic jackals.
This one...
There's that one there.
And I think we're gonna...
We're gonna post these
at @seacaptainpolls
to get your vote
for the favorite.
And also these are available
online at w-w-w-w...
[ Laughter ]
...dot late night merch...
front slash jackal.
[ Laughter ]
♪ These are the days ♪
♪ To remember ♪
♪ Never before and never since ♪
♪ I promise ♪
For "Weekend Update,"
I'm Seth Meyers.
Good night.